yeah hello and welcome to see your plane
schoolish from Spain let's go for Queens
gambit the funny a 6-line that recently
became popular because h3 I guess I can
do this yeah unlikely on queen bee three
that's probably Knight to c6 and h3 is
not really a move that scares black a
lot maybe g4 actually
[Music]
Wow very sharp position after gphone
maybe I go Bishop before then
[Music]
Queen B seven I just have Knight a5 also
em there is not just 94 95 traps the
Queen he takes f6 now takes d5 I'm
really well developed their funky line
him and maybe you can still just take
[Music]
just risk it so if i go night before now
[Music]
they also can unite 85 I mean that's not
totally ridiculous and screen a4 I can
go be five I mean be five or six they
both would work
be five and ten has to go back to d1
even though it's questionable if those
moves on the queenside relief and really
helped me
[Music]
yeah but it's an interesting position I
mean so he goes back I have to cancel at
some point
[Music]
I'm thinking of regrouping to this sixth
year it's often a good idea in those
structures it just that I now notice
that 96 of course blunders the poem on
the fire so I have to go to be six I
didn't I was thinking or playing c6
before not so forward I was worried that
he might go 92 anyway this is not a big
issue he has Queens gambit cars but
structure now with them traded
LightSquared bishops and this is
generally generally quite okay f is
surprisingly ambitious
[Music]
discourage you for I want to go night
cat6 of course but first of all with
this look opposite Queen I am thinking I
[Music]
think that I'm making it more difficult
for him to play form ideas 96 nine FC
four then f6 I can kick his night out
but the same does not apply for my
future knight on e4 at square Sam yes so
weakened that cannot use a pawn to
control control it but not so easy to
give wide advice here one thing is to
just play quicker it i mean i have the
same problem
[Music]
so we decided to just protect everything
and now it's not able to take we always
see a fork yeah I will take I will take
this one and now Queen f6 rupee 70 d to
e 8 i'm actually quite happy if he
weakens them self there with the pawn
push us I don't think that this leads to
much
[Music]
there are also now potential tactics
book takes you three in some cases this
looks we killing 25 probably know now if
Knight to f6 is doing much trading the
nygean since the lane
and now hs6 in denver CO h5 and a bit
it's an idea on f 69 f 7 it's also
interesting to do this wait i know i can
take
[Music]
mmm that position was really difficult
to handle there are everything was very
loose play please no means yeah I think
I'm almost certain that he had some
opportunity in the opening asics Wilson
there's an interesting line currently in
fashion aeg form was interesting but I'm
also quite interested in this so the
thing is we can probably take that's
what I was thinking yet his move yeah I
can take T prom league in its very
that's very know that I can take but
this is possible me
[Music]
okay the thing is that this is not clear
because I mean I'm very well-developed
ear canceled and that it's not not yet
organized Queen Queen yet there should
be six it's it's a good school
development and right it's not so easy
to play then III want to play again and
now I'm kicking it the screen bag can
see some rather comfortable without the
lights clippership I think the Indians
evaluation of equal is probably true but
I think f1 that could be questionable
maybe you should just play Knight back
to f3 what the nual suggests or take on
this having disposition as comfortable
for black word it's also nothing nothing
special and now i'm sitting on under on
the weaknesses and there's yeah it's not
not really nice i always get this and
and i know i don't like before either
with that it's difficult to play it hits
over it's just not so it's not easy for
what to do something forward yeah we
probably just have to keep the position
end don't too much at all some the in
the consulate structure with the light
squared Bishop strain it it's it's
difficult to do much in this particular
situation it was even difficult to get
in before in the first place any before
idea here it's currently hampered by the
bishop
and it before it's I mean the night has
a good square on c4p four players on
this is a fairly comfortable position ok
guys thanks for watching
[Music]